[Music]
so time then for the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
as they come into us it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
director of the demos think tank polly
mckenzie and the daily telegraphs chief
political correspondent christopher hope
they'll be joining us from now until
midnight speaking to them in a moment
first of all let's check out those front
pages for you we'll start with the
mirror it's spoken to security experts
who warned that the resurgence of the
taliban could effectively give al-qaeda
permission to conduct further attacks on
the west
the daily mail reports on british
paratroopers efforts to maintain control
of kabul airport describing it as our
boy's last stand
and the guardian also covers the
situation in car ball
meanwhile the ft leads with president
joe biden insisting the u.s and the
taliban are working together to get
americans who need to leave afghanistan
out of the country though the telegraph
goes with biden's admission that not all
americans may make it out alive
the times is concerned with whether or
not afghans themselves may have safe
passage out of their homeland
the sun leads with a miraculous escape
from a jail in kabul by a former british
soldier as the taliban entered the
capital
in other news the express splashes with
the approval of ranaphree the first drug
specifically designed to treat kovid19
and the star warns that the recent
chicken shortage experienced by nando's
could extend to turkey's come
christmas now we're joined by paulie
mckenzie and christopher hope a very
good evening to you both good to see you
this uh friday night um polly why don't
we start with you and the front page of
the daily telegraph i mean all the
papers uh pretty much uh have
afghanistan on the front pages and many
uh carrying pictures similar to this one
on the front of the telegraph a little
child there being lifted over the
barrier uh at the airport really
heartbreaking scenes we've witnessed uh
today our correspondent stuart ramsey
right in the middle of it all and joe
biden uh polly admitting this evening we
might not get everyone out
yeah there are echoes of
an interview that ben wallace our
secretary of defense gave just a couple
of days ago where he
he said the same thing there are with
tears in his eyes that there are some
people we we will leave behind both
potentially uk nationals but also allies
and and this is biden admitting
the same thing it was an interesting
press conference he took a lot of
questions
uh the telegraph is focusing on this
particular angle which is the the one
area where it felt like
president biden was kind of
admitting to weakness and lack of
strength what was surprising i think in
in his remarks is he he seemed to be
denying evidence on on some of the other
kind of questions that he was pressed on
about the impact on allies you know
any reporting even a single line of
reporting from what was said about the
us in just the british parliament would
would lead you to understand that this
has had an impact on american standing
it might still be the right thing to do
and president biden is absolutely
robustly defending that position but
to be implying as he did that it hasn't
had any consequence on
or any impact at all on on u.s allies
strikes strikes me as odd um because you
know and we're also seeing these these
heartbreaking images you know this child
here on the front of the telegraph
yesterday there were pictures of a
mother handing over a sick baby uh we've
seen people falling from airplanes as
they take off you know
now revealed to have been a young
afghan footballer so
to suggest that there isn't chaos to
suggest that um
that nobody is struggling to get to the
airport it's just defying what we are
seeing in these in these photographs and
video footage um
and and it will struck me as quite an
odd press conference for those reasons
yeah uh yeah many people saying saying
the same thing afterwards let's look at
the front page of the times christopher
uh similar picture there desperate mum
handing her a baby who's sick to a u.s
marine uh thousands of uk allies face
being left behind because of this uh
deadline the august the 31st and
interestingly a bit earlier on um the
u.s state department did say that
they've had assurances from the taliban
i don't if you heard this latest line
that um the deadline of the 31st of
august could be extended and that anyone
who wishes to leave afghanistan will be
able to which obviously would relieve
pressure at the airport but you know how
far do we trust the taliban
well we don't know yet the taliban
currently
you know mainly is on best behavior
certainly in kabul although that's not
the case in some outlying towns and
cities according to other reports but
you know you have to take them a degree
of face value um
this is this report by the times and i
think the telegraph is supporting it as
well tomorrow talks of how the pm boris
johnson feels let down by biden of the
chaotic withdrawal it's all driven of
course by the 20 year anniversary of 9
11. um so there is a you know it was a
few days after the 31st of august before
that deadline
but the risk is huge to biden and to a
lesser degree to the uk because if
people are left there british people are
left there um there are six thousand um
british and afghan citizens who need to
get out if they're left there just for
uk
and they and things happen to them
that's going to be
obviously dreadful politically highly
damaging
and i do think this is going to make a
prompt a reappraisal not least of our
intelligence and what we know about the
risk to this kind of thing happening
again that we were supposed to be caught
short there will be an inquiry i think
by the intelligence and security
committee into that but also the special
relationship with america whether
whether we'll be so keen to go into
foreign adventures with america in the
same way as we did all those years ago i
think it's a real reckoning i think in
the special relationship
um we'll just have a quick look at the
daily mail we won't necessarily dwell on
this because we need to move on but
i've personally been very struck today
at the professionalism of the powers out
in cardboard we've seen as i say
incredible footage today of the the
troops that are holding the line their
professionalism in what is a highly
stressful uh an emotional situation our
boys last stand in kabul the daily mail
have gone for but let's look at the
mirror poly
clear and present danger they've spoken
to colonel richard kemp former commander
of course of the british forces in
afghanistan
and he is making it very clear that al
qaeda will be back
yeah i mean we have to remember that for
all of their problems with this 20-year
project in afghanistan
we and the u.s did not
invade in the first place just you know
for the jolly it was because afghanistan
was a hotbed of uh terrorism training
camps and support for al qaeda which
enabled uh those horrific attacks on
911.
the intervention was necessary was it
well planned was there an exit strategy
clearly not and it has not been a
success
but
without uh the us and um
and and allied troops there with the
taliban now in charge and you know of
course remember afghanistan is a
complicated country lots of regional war
lords who um kind of families who may or
may not ally with the taliban who have
plenty of power in their own parts of
the country as well so it's it's not an
easy country to run even if the taliban
were to surprise us and be more uh more
reformists more anti-terror you've also
got you know the pakistan border regions
so this is a real danger which i think
it's important that the mirror is kind
of uh reminding us of at this point
yeah your thoughts on this christopher
well the hope is that this doesn't come
to pass taliban were last in power 20
years ago times times have changed the
hope is that they can respect women
properly you know they have taken
questions at that first amazing press
conference this week in in kabul the
worry is al-qaeda
if they can't establish authority the
taliban then these ungoverned spaces
will become breeding grounds for
terrorism that's what colonel richard
kemp is warning in that daily mirror
splash and that's going to be
well that's going to the legacy of
what's happening over the past seven
days and that's what we see reading
about and talking about a lot for months
to come yeah i'm just staying with you
christopher i just want to bring in the
uh the times um let's look at the
domestic situation with regard to uh
dominic rob we'll get polly's thoughts
on this uh in a moment but just staying
with you tory mp's turn on rob after a
week of chaos and carnage i mean has has
he written this out do you think or has
it still got a distance to run
well i've been told by very senior
government sources he has written
written it out if nothing else changes
there were no photographs yet of dominic
robin crete last saturday and sunday as
kabul fell now um a split picture of him
on his sunbed or playing tennis on the
beach against the horrors in kabul would
be very bad front pages on sunday they
haven't appeared yet they may not appear
um i've been told very clearly about
people very close to the pm that the pm
is happy for him to stay on he's not
going to go anywhere he thinks he's a
rather good front secretary good at
detail and is not off but there's no
question that i don't know what happened
last saturday but as kabul fell i mean
ben monaster said on friday that the
government was this being like like an
ice cube in hot sand well by saturday
why would boris johnson and dominic rob
were both unholy at the same time
dominick rabbi is the deputy to the pm
his first secretary of state this
shouldn't happen it looks um chaotic and
that's what kirstama did so well
highlighting in the comments on
wednesday the big concern is
intelligence why were our leaders our
political leaders not warned in advance
about happening and polly i want to get
i want to get a thought from you on this
ben wallis also said that one phone call
would have wouldn't have made a blind
bit of difference
well clearly no phone call from dominic
rob would have prevented the collapse of
the afghan government or the taliban
from taking kabul
the question is whether in those extreme
circumstances when you know so much as
at stake you will do whatever it takes
even if the chances of it helping very
much are small
there are questions here but i think as
christopher says the most important
questions are about this intelligence
failure you know we pulled combat troops
out of afghanistan eight years ago
this training and support mission it you
know it was long since been
known that the u.s were leaving on this
date that this would be happening
so the complacency which drove both our
thinking our planning and of course u.s
thinking and u.s planning is is the kind
of much more structural question i think
needs to be asked than you know whether
or not we get a picture of dominic rob
with his shirt off on the beach
okay polly uh christopher thank you both
for the moment coming up after the break
we'll discuss the reported 50 million
pound cost to the taxpayer of climate
change protests by extinction rebellion
that's financial
[Music]
hello again part two the press preview
now pauline christopher still with us uh
polly let's turn to the times extinction
rebellion more protests on the way and
they're expensive
yeah protests are both an essential part
of a functioning healthy democracy
including people protesting that you or
i might not agree with
uh and they're quite expensive to police
as is premier league football um i think
what's interesting actually is seeing
this story which is uh the met revealing
numbers for these these protests which
did include some extremely stupid
protest techniques i think somebody
glued themselves to a tube train or i it
was extremely stupid and disruptive in
my view um but it's also part of efforts
that you know we might come on to look
at later
by the government by the police to
justify the passage of a policing bill
through parliament that is going to
quite drastically curtail rights to
protest so it's part of and a
storytelling around that the idea that
protest is essentially a harmful and
expensive and and difficult thing
and actually i think it's uh we should
take these numbers you know slightly
with a little dose of skepticism it's
very convenient for the government or
for the met police at the moment to be
able to say this is terribly terribly
expensive wouldn't it be nice if we
didn't have any protests let's stop all
of these bad guys and just not have any
right to protest and that i think would
be a worse outcome yeah in fact several
of these arrests have been overturned
haven't they in recent weeks christopher
yes i mean i think polly's probably has
been a bit bit overly political on this
one possibly because xr is back in the
capital on monday and this is how the
met gets his retaliation in first
they're saying look at the cost to the
police of of allowing this to carry on i
do wonder how um the police are going to
police these protests on monday i i
lucky enough to work pretty privileged
to work in parliament overlooking
parliament square i watched it all take
place i watched a pink boat pull up last
year and um and then people glue
themselves to the undercarriage and then
the cops wouldn't go near them and and
they glued themselves to the road and
you do wonder whether um more robust
policing
may help and get um get things moving
i've seen ambulances turn around and
they can't get through parliament square
on the way to thomas's hospital that's
the worry so i think um it's important
that you can re you can protest i get
that and demos is keen on that of course
they are we are everyone is but equally
you have to have enough space to make
let emergency vehicles move around
london and you know life must carry on
too yeah we'll see what uh what develops
in coming weeks and and finally this
story on the front of the telegraph uh
sorry chris i'm going to give this to
polly i know it's your paper but polly
the chilton and cotswolds beautiful
parts of the country going to become
national parks
yes i think this is great news um
national parks are a brilliant idea been
around for you know 120 130 years to
have two more would be great my only
slight fear is that geoffrey clifton
brown the tory mp for the swells is
welcoming this basically in hopes that
it's going to constrain housing
development and i worry that this might
be too much of a sense of of nimbyism
actually we should have more people in
beautiful homes in beautiful parts of
the country and national parks should be
about preserving uh you know the access
to the countryside for human beings as
well as just kind of trying to
constrain development as perhaps sir
jeffrey would prefer okay christopher
come in on this 20 seconds
well i agree i think
let's sit back and it's great that you
have um
lovely places of this country being
protected further and being nice for
future generations
okay christopher and polly thank you
both very much